you're from Belfast and you have that
amazing accent really one person do you
find that the accent is hard for some
people to understand it can be
especially a cumbia in the States it is
but that's why I play around I think I'm
quite good at softening it when it needs
to be and then there's some times when
there when I really want something like
an in-n-out burger or something I'll do
an American accent just because I just
there's some things I don't want them to
get wrong so you're saying you will
switch to an American accent when
ordering and in and out Berta not just
in the night if I'm like staying if I'm
in the States for a while if I'm in New
York LA or something and I'm ordering
Chinese for the pizza or anything that's
like important to me yeah I will yeah
you know so they don't you know mess
ruined my order I'll do an American
accent what what is your can I just hear
what your in-and-out order sounds like
no I go for the I go for the it's not a
menu I go for the four by four four by
four yeah I'm not I'm not gonna start
that yeah yeah has anyone thought like
it's really it's the way it's the way to
go four patties and forward that's a
heart attack
four patties and four slices of cheese
yeah okay yeah and you just yelled at an
American accent when you're like you're
not screwing around no I think I don't
think you can say forespore patties and
four slices of cheese in an Irish accent
in an American I can only do it in a
really bad fake American version of an
Irish accent it's like having four
patties
that that you could maybe do I could get
about you know by the way that accent is
so offensive the times I've been to
Ireland
ya know Irish person talks anything like
that elephant like a and also in Ireland
we don't say things like top of the
morning to you I mean others like all
the thing making some like tiny villages
in the West of Ireland they still say
but no one says well they might say it
to tourists but the first time I went
over to Ireland to everyone that's like
top of the mornin to ya they beat the
[ __ ] out of sure
you